hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the trailer today for Mortal
Kombat X katana and Kung Lao gameplay
trailer I've seen several of these
gameplay trailers a lot of people were
asking that I checked this specific one
out yeah I mean the game looks [ __ ]
sweet it's a tenth installment let's do
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
finish
[Music]
or Oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah well smarty can I say that game
looks [ __ ] sweet you know what I
really dig about the Mortal Kombat
series I remember playing it like ages
ago when you know it was like real life
people you were playing as like Mortal
Kombat 2 and stuff a lot of these
fighting games you know the story tends
to not be so clear but as gameplay has
changed over the years we get much
clearer storylines this time around and
it's cool to see like how there's more
cinema to these kinds of to these kinds
of fighting games which makes the
violence ignore all that much better
I mean what's sweet about this is
there's all kinds of fighting styles
going on in this game and they're all so
[ __ ] deadly and you got great
characters the whole time and yeah it's
like gory it's incredibly violent but
because of the context in the world that
it's in sometimes I'm cringing and stuff
but it's still like cool to look at
counter magic a Kill Bill like it's so
over-the-top violent that sometimes you
just laugh at how violent it is I think
it was Kung Lao with that through it
like that circle thingy that starts
slicing into that one guy's face hmm
and when katana finishes off Kano and
this is like [ __ ] cuts his face
certain scale Sam it's it's grotesque
he gets me thinking that when they make
another Mortal Kombat movie you know
we've got two movies there's been talk
forever about Mortal Kombat legacy
becoming a film I think that they should
go all-out when it comes to the violence
and gore that's such a signature thing
about Mortal Kombat and I even felt like
Mortal Kombat legacy held back on that I
think if they make another movie they
should honor like over-the-top
ridiculousness of the kind of fighting
you know people are like flipping
through the air and then you're kicking
them while they're in the air and
slicing them up and stuff and it's like
super fast motion it's really [ __ ]
cool and I think if they make another
movie they should really go all out like
this anyway guys yeah I mean thanks for
telling me of that trailer result I
always dig these trailers if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects where I something's caught
in my throat Mayon come mmm
kaylynn Ellison hey can i have a shout
out if you don't I'll probably come find
you and fart in your food so you can
catch Ebola PS I forgot to congratulate
you on getting the girl who was way too
hot for you you're living the dream and
you have my full support
thanks buddy if you far to my food and I
catch Ebola I mean that's that's
horrible I'm I I so remember what Ebola
is I mean it's the talk I'm so in the
know of these things and what Ebola does
to your body and how bad it is I so
remember so I don't want it I think and
yeah
verónica way too hot for me I don't know
what she was thinking
but that's where you know really
shooting the girl up with a lot of
heroin really helps out and Kalon you
stay cool thanks for your support and I
hope that if you touch yourself you
touch yourself to me and not to my
girlfriend Tim Martin can I get a
shout-out mr. right I was born in Africa
and I'm in the mandingo fighting
business best reaction channel on
YouTube you're in the men dingo fighting
business that still exists no you're not
my name's Tim Martin you're a total
white dweeb the most I know about
mandingo is from Leonardo DiCaprio and
Django Unchained Tim good for you I mean
if you're from Africa that's awesome
I don't know if you're one of those
white guys from Africa but if you're a
black guy from Africa that means you got
a huge Dingling and you are naturally
cut
I didn't tell us of you you [ __ ]